at this point
uh fox news is a tool
for russian propaganda now i'm not
asserting any kind of collusion
i'm not saying russian
uh officials are feeding talking points
to fox news i'm not saying any of that
but what i am saying is fox news's
coverage of the russian invasion of
ukraine is really useful from the
standpoint of propaganda value to
russian state television i've previously
told you
about this memo this was about from
about a month ago exactly a month ago in
fact a kremlin memo
was sent to russian media
saying it's essential to feature tucker
carlson's commentaries in terms of their
uh coverage of the russian invasion of
ukraine and particularly early on
tucker's coverage was very very pleasant
for russian propaganda purposes so we
already talked about that previously
that's that leaked memo
we also uh
know
that russian state television has
referred to former democratic
congresswoman tulsi gabbard as our
friend
on the basis of her interviews with yes
also
with tucker carlson
and we now also have another example of
this
wherein um russian media
has aired
a clip from fox about so-called growing
concern over far-left lunacy in schools
which includes trans rights
clay travis was the guest a right-wing
media personality as he's often referred
to and that was also useful remember
that in the midst of the russian
invasion of ukraine russian state media
continues to be obsessed with a very
similar kind of anti-woke so-called
anti-woke ideology
that is very much in line with vladimir
putin's cultural
preferences cultural positions and
there's a lot of great material from fox
news when it comes to that so it's
always really important when we look at
these things to understand that
the term useful idiot is often really
useful and i know it sounds like a
pejorative but it's it's a it's a term a
useful idiot is someone who is being
used by others for their own gain
without even realizing it so very often
you know back in the trump-russia
investigation days
there were some
i guess who were setting their standard
as
is there going to be video of trump
colluding with vladimir putin and and
putin telling trump what he needs him to
do and whatever and and as i and many
others said
that's never going to happen that's not
how these things work we're not talking
about that what we're talking about is
more of a useful idiot relationship
where trump wouldn't even realize
that he is furthering the goals of
russia which is making the u.s look like
a joke which it was when trump was
president uh making our democracy appear
unstable by fomenting the idea that what
would it did the winner really win this
type of thing and similarly it's not
that russia's giving tucker carlson
talking points it's sort of similar to i
i hate to say this because i had friends
uh who who worked for rt television but
a lot of rt people used to all when rt
was still on the air in the u.s they
would say
they hired me
they never told me what i had to say
they never edited my script they never i
do whatever i want here
you were hired
either because what you are already
planning to say is useful to russian
state media or
because your presence by virtue of your
identity is useful even if you're not
towing the party line it's sort of like
you could say when shep smith was on fox
news and we would say he's the he's the
lone voice of reason
um
and it was the poi the whole point was
it allowed fox to say we're fair and
balanced we have all sorts of different
views here nobody was telling shep what
to say but he was on for one hour
and then the rest and then they could
say well you know we're fair and
balanced we have all sorts of views so
understand when we say useful idiot
it the term idiot is pejorative but
useful idiot in total
describes someone who is
unknowingly being used by others to
further their agenda and that's exactly
what we're seeing on fox news uh next
tuesday 6 pm eastern april 19th we'll be
doing the next david pakman show viewer
town hall i hope you'll join me
everybody's welcome to call in and it'll
be streaming live on our second youtube
channel that's youtube.com
pacman live we'll take a very quick
break and be right back
one of our sponsors is blissey giving
you 30
off blissey offers the nicest luxury
silk pillow cases you have ever felt on
your face i've been sleeping with blissy
pillowcases at home i have tried many
pillowcases the feel of blissey beats
them all
every blissy pillow case is made with
100
mulberry silk they're hypoallergenic
they are just super soft the type of
silk that blissey uses stays cool all
night even after using it for hours it's
still cool and perfect i get too hot
when i sleep the cooling factor makes a
big difference the protein based silk
blissey uses is also moisture wicking
which helps if you get sweaty while you
sleep blissey has earned high praise
from a ton of publications like good
housekeeping you can read their reviews
online blissey's having a huge mother's
day sale right now giving you 30 off
when you go to blissy.com
pacman and the link is down below